the Joe Rogan experience I think that's
what life is basically not share yeah
it's an analogy like we're always
worried about things we spent so much
time worrying about things most of which
never occur yeah you know and even the
ones that do occur it's like wow
whatever like death you know what is I'm
not worried about death dying maybe if
it takes too long but if it's if it
takes like an hour or a day to die
that's a tiny fraction of your life who
gives a [ __ ] you're not a guy that
really spends a lot of time working on
fitness or you you enjoyed that article
I take it as a compliment things to do
than work out Joe I get it you enjoyed
that article that I wrote a long time I
did the sand
yeah human bodies like a sandcastle yeah
yeah you can make it beautiful but it's
not gonna last
yeah and you know that going in you know
that way yeah and I and I mean I've got
this idea for a book mmm if I keep
writing books which is sort of a
self-help book but it's a parody of
self-help books and so it'll be it'll be
calling attention to the way so much of
what we do to try to be healthy is
actually counterproductive because we
stress especially Americans everything's
work you know everything turns into work
and Americans are very suspicious of
pleasure we're taught to that pleasure
is you know evil and dangerous and all
this hmm I've never bought that line of
reasoning I've always felt like what
feels good generally is good there's a
reason it feels good you know now that
can get corrupted by advertising and
false messaging from a sick society that
tells you you know sit on the sofa and
drink beer and eat bags of chips all day
but if you get beyond that and you can
actually hear the voice of your body I
think if your body is telling you to you
know stay in bed because it's a rainy
cold day and now I know this is totally
against your perspective on life where
you're like you gotta tame the inner
[ __ ] you got to get out of bed you got
to work out it doesn't matter I'm like
no man I'm staying
bad like you you go to what you need to
do I used to climb mountains with this
friend of mine in Spain and he was like
you he was a [ __ ] billy goat he'd
like go up there and I'd go with him
till I got to a nice spot with a nice
view and I'd be like dude I'll be here
when you come down taking a nap
got a bottle of wine and some cheese I
appreciate that too I'm not married to
my perspective but I think I have a very
peculiar biology that demands a certain
amount of exertion yeah
sure something and I friends like that I
mean I you know I've lots of friends
like man I if I don't run every day I
feel like [ __ ] I'm like running is very
addictive though I feel fine yeah you
get you get used to that there's a high
that you get from running that's really
interesting and any long-term
cardiovascular exercise you get this
it's like we did you know what last last
October we did the silver October thing
where we have this crazy fitness
challenge so all of us were doing cardio
like five hours a day really crazy
amounts of cardio and one of things that
Tom Segura and I both agreed on is like
the the amount of internal chatter
dissipates to zero
like you've no anxiety it goes I didn't
realize I had any anxiety until that
happened and then I was like God it goes
to zero it goes to nothing like when you
do like five hours on a treadmill or
just running just run when you win it's
done man
there's this like peace of mind that
comes with that this release of
endorphins that's incredibly addictive
because that feeling is so pleasing so
it's not that it doesn't it doesn't feel
good to get out of bed and and to just
push when you don't want to but the end
result feels amazing it does so I like I
wonder if there's any research looking
into whether that effect happens
universally because I've worked out
I've run there were times in my life I
never I've never gotten a runner's high
never I get my teeth hurt my knees hurt
my back hurts I feel my brain
you know bouncing around in my skull you
know I'm half a mile into it I'm like
[ __ ] this this doesn't feel good you
have to get in shape first that's a big
part of it it's not it's not that simple
it's like for me uh I never really got
into running I like the first time I
really did any serious running I my
friend cam Haynes had a 5k which is what
is that three miles some way that's some
like and I didn't run at all in
preparation for it and when I ran the 5k
I was like Jesus Christ this is hard
like I didn't have a there was no good
feeling at all yeah you know it's
running on concrete and [ __ ] right in
Vegas it's gross in Vegas Melanson in
the air and but when it was over I was
like okay obviously I'm not I'm in good
shape but not in good running shape at
all so I should probably get in shape
for this so then I started running and
then when I got into running in at
particularly running hills then I
started feeling it once I kind of got in
that kind of shape and then when the you
know when the workouts are over like I
run all the time now and when it's over
I just have this ha yeah you and
Marshall or yeah doing your thing it's
great yeah [ __ ] lot and he loves it
too there's no crazy bonding experience
with that dog you know because he loves
it yeah I got my dad a golden retriever
the best dog years ago when my dad was
like you know maybe its genetic is he's
pretty lazy he came home from work and
you know sit in front of TV and drink
vodka and get upset about the news and
and my mother didn't like dogs but like
my sister and I convinced her that dad
needs a dog because dad will get this
dog and he'll go for walks cuz the dog
needs to walk and so we got no golden
retriever he named it Stoli
bad sign right there and then and then
he never went for walks totally just sat
next to them and got fat Wow it's common
doesn't always work no yeah it helps me
get going because I know that he needs
exercise
yeah it does but it helps me too and
it's fun like I talked to him when we
run
you know I guess we're running you know
I have little conversations with them
yeah cool fun he's not judging you right
really I'm a [ __ ] I could be fat covered
and [ __ ] they probably prefer that more
interesting
yeah it's but the the runner's high is a
real thing but you have to achieve some
level of fitness before I think it kicks
in
[Applause]